I'm Michael Weatherly
when I'm bringing to the show is is is
definitely not the buff Beauty thing
what I'm bringing to the show is
actually still a mystery to many of the
people who work with the show they've
been trying to figure out what that is
that an extra component way back in the
archives this morning bill gates now
after Michael Weatherly that puts
Michael speaking to Entertainment
Tonight in 1994 instead of the soap
opera loving it was one of his first
acting jobs okay every minute of it
Weatherly later made a name for himself
a special agent Anthony DiNozzo on the
hit CBS drama NCIS look how cute you
were yeah and guess what you're still
cute now he plays a psychologist on the
CBS series Bowl he plays dr. Jason bull
runs a consulting firm that uses
psychology and technology to pick the
perfect jury for the desired outcome of
each trial so in this preview of the
season two premiere he tries to convince
a colleague they're gonna take a case
he'll give you a check for a quarter of
a million dollars the Clayton family
estate they're pressuring the DEA to try
the young widow Clayton for the murder
of her husband murder based on based on
the fact that she shot him a fact she
does not dispute can you say money in
the bank okay but according with the
paper the late mr. Clayton was
attempting to slice and dice his dearly
beloved just prior to her deciding to
use him for target practice I believe
they call that self-defense maybe or
maybe she shot first and he stabbed her
in self-defense
who cares it's a quarter of a million
dollar retainer and another quarter of a
million if we actually go to trial and
find mrs. Clayton guilty wow I had no
idea the famous dr. Jason bull can be
bought for a quarter million dollars not
only can I be bought you can gift wrap
me please Michael we're looking back at
the table you know what Michael he's
cocky got lots of swagger is that
difficult for you to play yeah I don't
know where I got that hard well he is
that episode is called school for
scandal and he's a scoundrel yes this
character is cut from a certain cloth
you've got a new showrunner who said
let's change things up what didn't tell
ya well last year and we launched really
successfully and and it's at
clever conceit that phil mcgraw and
Paulette nausea came up with and Paul
was one of the guys who created house
and and was involved in that and you
know mr. Spielberg helping produce the
project as always that's always a corner
so we came out of the box really strong
but I think last year they everyone
collectively said how can we make the
show even you know even bigger and
better and always trying to improve
things we brought in Glenn Gordon Karen
who created moonlighting Mike we have
medium and he has a silver tongue What
did he say he said he's bulls too
perfect he's bulletproof pardon the pun
and we got to break him up and make him
flawed and vulnerable and poorest and
and that's just been a blast because now
I don't know what's gonna happen and
page the page so what are some of his
vulnerabilities well he he has a hard
time sleeping in bed so he sleeps on his
couch quite a bit and usually there's a
bottle of something next to him when he
wakes up so he has a couple of not water
no oh it's not so he's got he's got some
self-destructive tendencies and he's
also a bit of a flim-flam man and he
wings it and sometimes when you're in
charge of somebody else's life and they
catch you winging it they don't really
appreciate that too much so it's based a
little bit on who talked to yeah didn't
open meet da Kapil when he was a
consultant yeah yes that's that's how
most people know of dr. Phil because
Oprah she says Charlie that without dr.
Phil she wouldn't have won that case he
was a trial consultant for the big beef
trial and she brought in dr. Phil McGraw
who as you know is very blunt speaking
very much truth-telling
but that's part of it as he sees it
right I mean that's also part of owning
the perspective and manifesting
something and creating the conversation
you want to have and it's a tactic and I
think it's based on him what's his
involvement in the show well he you know
every week Phil's involved
episode 2 episode and and is working
closely with Glenn Karen on sort of the
worlds that you get involved in you know
when you're trying to do jury analysis
that's one thing of the show that we
concentrated on a lot but now what we're
concentrating on is the character of
bull and how
he is held together with duct tape
basically you gonna get love this
there's a lot of money I don't mean get
love yeah going on fine love fine
there's some funny things and Melania
keeps calling him which is they're
having a sort of secret conversation and
the bats not true I just make things you
know he prides himself on being able to
read people in their characters can you
do that no not at all I mean I can't I
have a three maybe five year old they
are a complete mystery to me I try to
anticipate my dog I can understand my
dog because it's you food or a ball or a
walk but we've heard at your house the
tooth fairy's very generous yes absence
at your place there's a lot of well how
much do you all does a tooth fairy pay
for seven dollars we pay in our house
with inflation I very get that figured
that's all do you remember how much you
got forward to not $7 no mine was a two
chocolates there's a little Wow those
we're trying to kill the other team well
they're also genius children they have
good taste in television they want
favorite shows Charlie Rose oh yeah yes
yeah they have they have become
strangely addicted to Charlie which is I
guess America we attract all ages yeah
variety of you've got a nice on this is
us so what show are you watching I know
so if this is us as our direct
competitor at nine o'clock 8:00 central
on on Tuesdays so I have not seen my
lovely niece Alex on this is us but I
hear she does it wonderful right Phoebe
are people is very good to Bulls all
right and graduates Michael tell you
thank say hello do you kids I really
thank you
Michael Weatherly a fan thank you so
much you can watch the season two
premiere of Bowl on Tuesday night at
9:00 Eastern 8:00 central right here on
CBS